mid suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-south district council
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
and please note that messages in the
chat panel can be viewed by people
watching the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members
we have councillor ebola council of
field and councillor willem joining us
today
also in attendance are the chief
executive and the deputy monitoring
officer
thank you very much can i move to the
agenda
please item one is apologies for absence
we have no apologies for absence today
chair
thank you very much item two to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
while they're ready to declare
no thank you very much item three
is mca 20-25
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-suffolk cabinet
meeting
held on the 4th of january 2021.
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes please
could i have a proposal please um yes
chair councillor flatman here
i'm happy to um propose the minutes of
the fourth of
january thank you councillor flatman and
can i have a second to please
um thanks um councillor having him here
yes i'm happy to second the minutes
lovely thank you councillor the
governance officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair members if you could go
to the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
of your mod gov app
the vote for this item
should now show one moment
should now show as in progress thank you
just waiting for one vote
thank you members that's nine votes for
chair that's unanimous
thank you the minutes of the meeting
have been confirmed and will be signed
at the next practicable opportunity
moving on to item 4 to receive
notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
non-received chair thank you item 5
questions by councillors non-received
chair
and item six is matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny
or the joint audit and standards
committees
and i'll now invite councillor who is
chair of the overview and scrutiny
committee to introduce the report
thank you
thank you chair uh yes um
mr overview and scrutiny committee
considered a draft
general fund budget and four-year
outlook on the 14th of january
i made it clear that members of the
committee should consider whether or not
there was sufficient and clear
information in the report
and if the budget allocations were
appropriate i also made it clear that
any political statements and
preferences should be aired at the full
council meeting on the 18th of february
not a
overview of scrutiny with that in mind a
number of suggestions were made
when members felt that greater clarity
would assist council in
understanding the budget the pros their
proposals
also in respect of the overarching
principles in paragraph 6.4 on page 39
members felt that staff welfare and
mental health
are of great importance and a reference
to
a strong focus on well-being of staff
which has been added to that paragraph
is to be welcomed
the committee also re requested that
additional funding be allocated for
planning enforcement and legal costs
associated with planning
enforcement and legal issues around
planning and planning appeals
are often raised by residents and local
councils
and it is considered additional
resources would lead to an improvement
in the service
and a reduction in concerns and
complaints
raised with members also
the draft budget presented to overview
and scrutiny
on the 14th of january did not include
specific grant applications
and uh and allocations however the
report to overview and scrutiny on the
15th of february sets out allocations to
citizens advice
but does not include an index linking to
the grant
to mid suffolk citizens advice um
we request that you confirm that index
linking on a rolling three-year
agreement is intended
um citizen's advice are aware that a
separate application needs to be made by
each separate community and citizen's
advice
to preserve the three-year rolling
agreement with index linking
so the recommendations from overview of
scrutiny are set out on page 13
and i'm happy to attempt to answer any
queries thank you
thank you councillor willam does anybody
have any
questions
no i'll
press on and with the um the draft hra
account and the um four-year outlook
um members considered the report and
appendices and commended offices on the
quality of the report there were a
number of queries around capital
receipts and right to buy
which were dealt with by officers very
few other comments were made
and the committee resolved to endorse
the hra budget and four-year outlook
and the recommendation is set out on
page 21.
again if there are any queries i'll be
happy to try to respond
thank you any questions anybody
no brilliant excellent
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much
item seven forthcoming decisions list
does anybody have any comments on that
no item 8 mca
20 28 special urgent decisions taken by
officers during the
kovic 19 pandemic period under delegated
powers in accordance with part two of
the constitution
so the the recommendation
is um as listed in
appendix a on
page 29
does anybody have any questions
okay this is for noting only thank you
very much
item nine is mca 20
29 and is the general fund budget for
the
2021-22 and the
year outlook i'll now invite the cabinet
member for finance
to introduce this report
thank you madam chairman am i alive and
visible
yes okay thank you okay thank you i'm
pleased now to introduce the report on
the general fund budget for 2122
and the four-year outlook which is
referenced as mca 2029
and starts on page 31 of our report pack
subsequent to the draft budget being
debated here in january went before the
ons committee on the 14th of january
members of that cross party committee
did ask some pertinent questions and
made some very helpful observations
as we've already seen under item six of
today's agenda
uh during my introductory speech to
january's cabinet
i suggested that funds be set aside out
of the business surplus
to fund plan legal costs and plan
planning enforcement actions i re
reiterated those ideas at lns
and i'm pleased to say they would appear
to endorse them wholeheartedly
thus including the budget figures before
you today are a sum of half million
sorry a quarter million pounds put into
reserve for planning legal costs
and a sum of fifty thousand pounds put
into reserve for planning
enforcement actions of course our
residents expect us to be prudent
and frugal with our expenditure but also
believe they would equally expect us to
be robust in defending any planning
appeals that arise
and also to not shy away from any
planning enforcement actions
that are clearly justified and to do
these things properly does cost money
and with this budget the funding is
there
now there's been a significant change
from the draft budget in one area
in particular i'm speaking of our
retained income from business rates
uh members should note that during the
ons meeting councillor casten did query
the lack of growth in business rates
and our section 151 officer responded by
explaining that the draft budget figures
were based on february 2020 information
as we only submit data annually each
january to government
so we always knew that revised figures
from from that government return
would be incorporated into the report
now before you today
the baseline business rates have
increased by 1.588 million
driven in large part from the large
electricity substation at bradford
that's come on stream the prior business
rates deficit has also moved by 762
000 so it's now in a surplus position of
678
000 taking these in conjunction with
other more modest adjustments
our funding has now been revised upwards
by 2.39 million
now even as i speak these business rate
figures are being carefully scrutinized
by members of the finance team
and some down revisions are still likely
every year i express my frustration
about the local government settlement
only being announced just before
christmas as that is not helpful to the
budget process
and clearly late revisions of this
magnitude of our business rate numbers
in january are equally if not more
frustrating but thankfully
at least the adjustments are positive in
our agenda addendum papers members will
find in addition to this budget report
covering
the flexible use of capital receipts our
section 151 officer can explain this
flexibility in more detail
should members have any questions on it
but having reviewed it myself
i would put this opportunity quite
firmly into what i call
a no-brainer category and therefore
strongly recommend its adoption for 2122
and potentially beyond
as an administration we have a great
vision for the future of our district
great visions of course need substantial
resources
and despite the significant setback to
our economy from kovid19
the improved financial outlook set out
in this budget when combined with our
healthy brought forward reserves
we can look to the future with real
confidence and ambition
we now anticipate ring fencing 4 million
from our growth and efficiency fund to
spend on our key strategic priorities
of economy housing community and
well-being
in addition the amount we will raise
this year from the 1.66
increase in castle tax a sum of hundred
and four thousand pounds
we transferred to a new reserve for
covid related
business recovery in conclusion at a
time when we hear that some councils
across the country are facing real
significant hardship having to make
difficult cuts to key services
or even having to worry about issuing
section 114 bankruptcy notices
i do trust that cabinet today will be
happily to endorse
this sound and healthy budget for
recommendation through to full council
accordingly i'd like to pose the
recommendations to that effect
in the 3.1 of our report to oppose the
council tax increase 1.66 set out in
recommendation 3.2
and to endorse the full council the
flexible use of capital receipts
are set out of recommendations 3.3 and
3.4
i would look to it look for a seconder
thank you councillor do we have a second
day yes we do uh madam chair
it's councillor gould here and um i i
was delighted to
second um the budget report when it came
to our january meeting
and i'm i'm equally delighted to
second uh this this report um
i won't repeat the things that i said uh
at that earlier meeting
um i will have things to say when when
it made
its uh third appearance as it were
before before the council
um but safe to say i i will
repeat my thanks to or i'm sure our
collective thanks to the finance
team uh the professional team and and to
council whitehead himself for the
professional way
he has led that work uh and
and to our collective benefit um
in terms of you know john has made cats
white has
made reference to the improved business
receipts
uh position um
and i you know i suppose
the large station planford might be
considered good luck in a way but it's
often been said that the more effective
and successful
you are the more luck you seem to get um
and uh maybe that's the case uh here
i i don't know finally having spent
a good part of my career trying to argue
for more flexibility on the use of
capital receipts
let's not let this opportunity uh to go
by
here and take the recommendations in the
report
thank you very much thank you very much
councillor gold
so i'm now going to take questions
from well anybody really um
put if you can use the hands up function
and i'll take questions from cabinet
members first
followed by anybody else who's got a
question
councillor fleming
thank you thank you um chairman and
thank you very much
um councillor whitehead i just wanted to
draw attention to paragraph um
7.9 where we um discuss
allocating an additional 500 000 to the
work of the climate change task force
which brings us up to over the two years
approximately a million pounds allocated
to to that work i would it's really
both maybe a question and a
clarification that
um the biodiversity task force
work um is included within that
and that um we anticipate um
committing funds and um
you know taking taking forward a lot of
the actions
of that task force in the near future
and the fact that
um on the surface it looks as if not
very much of it is spent
actually an awful lot of work has gone
on and believe me
it will be spent thank you
thank you councillor fleming did you
want to respond
counselor yes i'm not quite sure
exactly where the question was there but
but the i can say
it's approximately to the nearest penny
one million pounds
grant i i think what i'm really saying
is that this includes
biodiversity and ecological work and
is not limited to the climate change
action plan
just so that everyone is very clear on
that point which i think is really
important
yes absolutely why we've got the reserve
renamed to say
it's climate and biodiversity
yes we need to get used to saying that
thank you absolutely
thank you castlefield
thank you bit quicker than i expected
um i must inject before i ask a question
that
i think branford's entirely due to the
local council councillor
you may have a different view seriously
just a question is that uh
very useful council tax inquiry um
business business rating contribution
entirely a north sea
wind related issue so it's the
termination of those
wind farms or or is it associated with
the other expansion and con
activities at branford for instance the
uh
connection for the uh proposed solar
farms that are there
so that's one point i do want to ask
whether
our very sound financial position at the
moment
uh is is a significant contribution
element for that the uh our relatively
low dependence
uh on incomes from sales we sell
things like car parking um
spaces obviously but we we lack large
theaters and things like that that have
suffered tremendously so is that a
significant
contribution or are there other elements
that are missing
and i think the third one to stick at
three um i noticed
in table six i think it is there's um
there's obviously a series of forecasts
and it just surprised me that the
business rate grant stays essentially
level within uh what's that four
thousand pounds
uh over the period of twenty twenty
twenty four
five and there seemed to be a whole load
of
things there that are just absolute
repeats
year on year of exactly the same numbers
is that uh because of the difficulty of
forecasting or
is is that really what we expect or are
we not taking into account things like
the government's acceleration of the
compensation for business rights
three questions now i think thank you
council field
um in terms of your comment about
branford i'll happily pass that on to
councillor castin
um in terms of your
quest other questions um sorry
put me off my stride now growth in
business
rates um the um
i i don't i don't know the details
myself in terms of whether how much has
to do with
the wind farms and how we should do the
solar farms i mean it took me a bit by
surprise that
i mean i know it's a very large
development up there but i was surprised
just the sheer
scale of it um but um also the business
rates figure
has revised covers growth in in all
areas but i'm told that is the
primary driver in terms of
i think you say saying selling car
parking spaces do you mean car parking
income on but yes yes to what extent is
it the fact that we
we don't focus extensively on on
selling things like that and therefore
our
income is relatively fixed compared with
others we could mention or
am i misinterpreting that i think so i
mean obviously
you know compared to some tourist areas
i guess our car parking we don't have
the same
opportunity to sort of charge people
four pound an hour like some places do
um and we don't have the same exposure
to theaters say as it's which borough
council
but there is such a such a wide range of
various income streams um that we we do
get in
um so uh the uh you know
that's why we're trying to reduce our
reliance on council tax and
uh you know going forward and in terms
of the at table six
my understanding i'll i'll refer to
catherine just to
clarify or contradict but the
you know we revise those numbers on this
annual basis when we do this january
turn
and but we don't at this present have
anyway sort of forecastle sort of
crystal ball ahead
for future years which is why we put the
latest figures for the
new budget year and now we have them and
then assume they continue
over the next four years but if
catherine would like to just
add to that
thank you chair and thank you councillor
whitehead
yes i think councillor field was saying
you know is it
difficult to forecast ahead and and i
think the simple answer is
is yes because quite a lot is going to
change around business rates over the
next
year or two we've had the fair funding
review has been
put on hold business rates reset has
been put on hold
so at the moment i think until we know
more about where some of those are going
and if the government does ever move to
75
retention of business rates that will
change things
as well so at the moment it's a case of
what we would change them to if we
didn't so we've taken the uh
stance of just going flat at the moment
with the with the figures for 21 22 and
then we'll revise as we get more
information
could i just ask if that then
means we're taking a pessimistic or an
optimistic view of
you know the future years up to say 24
20. i say it's approach it's a prudent
view to
to assume no growth but again catherine
might want to just after that
i was going to say i i haven't got a
magic crystal ball in terms of the
economy and where it's going to go and
how it's going to recover obviously from
the kovit pandemic so as councilor
whitehead said it it sort of feels like
a prudency thing to do at the moment
until we have more experience
right yeah thank you
thank you council field councillor eben
thank you very much chair um and thank
you to councillor whitehead for your
um comments and introduction of the of
the budget um there today and i
apologize i couldn't make
the meeting in january um when you
discuss this originally
um i've got two questions if i may um
firstly
i'm just not clear about what is the
logic of budgeting for a three
million pound surplus um as mentioned in
paragraph 7.4
um you mentioned priorities that
certain priorities that you're going to
put
money away for for future spend
but surely these should be live projects
within the core
budget so that our communities can
actually see what their
council tax is being spent on
so if you could explain um what why it's
been done that way thank you
and secondly um on paragraph 8.18
8.18 you refer to a
increase in service charges for the use
of endeavour house
at 43 000 pounds a year
but it's been suggested that we may not
ever fully move back into endeavour
house
and at least not in the um amounts of
people as before and where most
companies um
including some of our civic tenants are
negotiating rents
um downwards so why are we paying for an
increase um
thank you very much chair and thank you
for allowing me to ask the questions
thank you councillor white ted yeah yes
thank you classic even um
the you make a good point
um in terms of the uh you know the the
three million pound surplus and the
logic
uh the um you know our strategic
priorities uh you know cover a vast area
i had to say in terms of housing economy
communities and well-being and um
as i said in my introduction we're going
to put four million pound across those
four possibly in equal amounts we'll see
how it comes forward
but um those plans still are well beyond
the embryo stage but um
not really in detail enough to um put
um real meat on the on in terms of this
current budget
but the reality is that money is there
and the ambition
is to to spend that over the next
12 to 24 months and
um i think in terms of the final
presentation coming forward next week
those extra amounts will
will feed through so the surplus at
least on the face of it
will not seem as as large as that
and sorry and just your second point
eight eight eighteen
and the service charges i'm not sure
this might was either raised at
cabinet in january or over you know
scrutiny i forget which ones but
this the those are a figure that's been
put in
again prudently into the budget but the
reality is that's subject negotiation
and obviously the amount we get charged
will be based on that negotiation figure
and obviously we won't just pay the
budget figure without
a great deal of extra work beyond today
okay thank you very much for that
councilor wyatt um if i could just come
back to
um you mentioned plans being made for
the
housing um economy communities and
well-being
um when will we see um the first of
those come forward please thank
you
well i would say from late spring
through summer
um we'll be um bringing these forward
at least in part i mean they are because
they're ambitious and because they do
cover
areas right across the council that they
will
i'm sure they'll come forward at varying
speeds but um
the watch this space is i'd like to say
thank you very much thank you chair
thank you
counselor yes thank you check
can i seek the reassurance that i asked
for when i spoke before
that the um the grant to um
citizens advice mid-suffolk is
index-linked the same question was
raised at baber district council in
respect of sudbury and i believe
it was agreed there that the these two
um
allocations are indexed linked so if if
i could have that
that confirmation that would be really
useful thank you
um about being catholic at one stage
just to be sure in terms of
how much we can um sort of commit beyond
you know the following year's budget and
i'd sort of make the case i think
in terms of index linking when inflation
is now below one percent it obviously
isn't as critical as it was in
some of the bad old days but um but
myself
you know in terms of making sure that
grounds like that
um just don't decay by inflation
um i think that is critical and scaffold
could just respond in terms of
the three-year commitment
and i know um when overview scrutiny
previously looked at the citizen vice
bureau i think it then went as a
recommendation into cabinet that we
looked at
rolling three-year funding for citizens
and vice bureau which
from memory i think was was agreed by
cabinet
i couldn't remember precisely about the
index linking part of the recommendation
but i think for the grants for
mid-suffolk if that is
index linked to say something like two
percent then it's a cost of just two
thousand pounds so
that's uh well affordable within within
mid suffolk's budget
yeah i mean the principle i think is is
there and agreed it's just obviously
if that takes us beyond the may 23
elections
we can't really make any commitment
beyond there for example
we will get that clarified council thank
you very much
thank you so i'm now going to open up
the item for debate
so if anybody wishes to debate can you
use the hands up function
i think we might be a bit debated out on
this one
okay so i now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors the vote
is now in progress on your modguav app
thank you members uh chair that's nine
votes for that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed so moving on
now to item 10
which is mca 20-30
and this is the housing revenue account
budget
for 2021 to 22 and the four-year outlook
and i'm going to ask the cabinet member
for finance to introduce this report
thank you madam chairman okay i'd like
to introduce a report
on the housing revenue account um budget
for your outlook
since we looked at the draft budget in
our fourth of january meeting
the report has subsequently been
scrutinized by mid-southwest
ovum scrutiny committee at their meeting
i'd like to thank that committee for
their work on this as it does form an
important integral part of our budgeting
process
the committee's comments are included
within our report back today
and i'm grateful for their endorsement
of this hra budget
and trust that the cabinet will take
into consideration the comments made at
that meeting
there's been just some very minor
changes to the numbers in the hre budget
before you today compared to january's
draft
the housing management expense lines
increased by nine thousand
the building services expense line by
five thousand
so overall just an additional fourteen
thousand expense added
so accordingly the hr budget surplus
2122
has reduced from the sixteen hundred and
sixteen thousand report in january
now to a hundred and two thousand but
when our annual income and expenditure
totals are
each over fifteen million you'll
understand why i just refer to these
adjustments as very minor changes
so in essence nothing has really changed
the draft budget the cabinet reviewed
so nothing further to add beyond what
i've already said
when introducing that report to cabinet
and overview scrutiny
i do have however appreciate that
members have had a few more weeks to
study and contemplate the budget and
therefore be happy to answer any
further questions that they may have and
madame chairman if you just indulge me
for a moment before i move to the
recommendations
normally i'd held back from thanking our
finance team for all their hard work and
a budget until full council
but today though we have sharon bailey's
payless with us who's moving on from the
finance team to join cassandra clements
team
and sharon's role has been a linchpin in
the budget preparation for several years
so i'd like to thank her now on behalf
of cabinet for all she's done over the
years
to wish her well in her new role i'd
like and now i'd like to move the
recommendations three point one to three
point seven
i set out on page 87 would invite
councillor hadding and his cabinet
member for fi
housing if she would like to second them
these recommendations include giving
cabinet endorsement to the hra budget
before your outlook as it goes to full
council on the 18th of february
thank you thank you
councillor thank you madam chair
as the portfolio holder for housing i
would like to thank my fellow portfolio
holder for finance for his introduction
to the
hra budget for the year 2021-2022
the assistant director for housing gavin
fist and the housing and finance teams
have put a lot of hard work into this
report and i'd like to thank them on
behalf of the cabinet for that
the income the hra receives is
invaluable in supporting our tenants by
ensuring their homes are safe decent and
places they're proud to call home
the work of our fantastic team supports
tenants to manage and maintain their
tenancies
while supporting them to succeed and
thrive which during a pandemic has been
an incredible achievement
i would also like to point out to
members the key achievements listed on
page 91 of our
papers it is evident from the report
that the service is continuing to build
on its solid foundations
and as such i'm very happy to second it
and the recommendations set outs in it
within paragraph three
thank you very much thank you councilman
and i'd like to endorse the entire
cabinets and indeed the entire council's
thanks to shannon bayless for the work
that she's put in
um for this group over the last few
years and wish her well in a new role
thank you do we have any questions
thank you very much chair um and and i'd
um endorse the thanks for sharing as
well because i think
housing the um 30-year business plan so
on the finances for housing have been
particularly um complex over the last
few years and
um i would um anyone who can get their
head around it fully
and put together a good budget it
deserves our thanks
but i'd like to ask um on recommendation
3.4 refers to the sheltered housing
service increase of one pound per week
um could you um tell me
what that is as a percentage please so
how much as a percentage that's
increasing
thank you very much
um perhaps i could ask gavin
fisk no sorry i'm here
to do a little calculation because the
the one-pound increase that
the unlike baby all our i think it's 13
or 14
sheltered housing schemes all have the
same charge at the moment
which i believe is i believe is 30 pound
an 83p it might be a 30 pound 85
but that's that one percent one pound is
about 3.2
3.25 percent uh increase
um i think i think yeah i'm trying to
work off memory now
i think it was three pound eight would
be needed to fully recover all the costs
so
the one pound is a relatively small
contribution towards reducing the
subsidy
thank you very much thank you chair
thank you
councillor field
hey thank you again with my microphone
switched on um
thank you uh just a couple of questions
um just on that issue of sheltered
housing
i really just wanted confirmation that
do we consider the
social value of that housing uh and the
issues of
you know reduced charges on other
services from the district um
for the district county social care
public health et cetera nhs
uh when when we consider that issue that
we we do provide obviously a subsidy but
it might be a subsidy that achieves
a great deal so really do do we consider
that was one issue it was uh
one question the other one really is to
return to the cpi plus one percent
increase
um for residents who obviously at the
moment like most people are having
struggle making ends meet
um i know further on in sections four
six and four
nine you you mentioned that uh rent
levels are
at risk you know the risk of collecting
these
effect is significant and
really once again seeking you are sure
that this
is not going to make that issue worse
thank you
thank you sorry having controlled my
buttons here are clicking on and off
um in terms of the sheltered housing and
and sort of wider
aspects that you brought into that i
think that sort of
is strained well beyond the sort of
basic cabinet
member finance role so i'd probably
probably ask gavin to sort of make some
comments on that
uh and in terms of the cpi plus one
percent
um the um all the adjustments over the
last six years mean that the
the rent going forward in april 2021
will be only just very marginally ahead
of where it was in
march 16. i mean putting any increase on
anything
in terms of collecting by definition
would make it somewhat harder to to
collect but um again i'd be happy to
just
defer to to gavin for his thoughts on
all these matters thank you
yes so i invite our assistant director
for housing gavin fisk to respond to
that
thank you chair and uh thank you
councillor whitehead and council of
field
i think just in terms of the first
question in relation to the subsidy
um let's just be clear that the subsidy
is in relation to the
management and provision of services
within each of those schemes
and that could include the services of
the scheme manager
uh the the services within the scheme
laundry's lifts
and then obviously health and safety and
other factors
um we did discuss at a recent cabinet
meeting that
actually we are going to be looking at a
fundamental review of service charging
in sheltered housing
over the next 12 months and um my
recollection was that councillor
whitehead agreed and supported that
actually
uh that would involve cross-member
involvement and our plan is to develop
that this year
subject to obviously uh covert so that
work is already beginning
um just in relation to sherwood housing
and and that subsidy i think
actually uh what we provide uh residents
is is really good value for money
but what we do know is that uh what
tenants and what potentially potential
tenants of the future
um actually want and require uh
possibly will look different and
sherwood housing has to move
with the times as as anyone uh does so i
think
when we're listening to to the views one
thing that we often hear is
is um it's around quality it's around
size
type uh location and benefits and as
such i think
we've already set out in our plans to
conduct a sort of wider review of
sheltered housing
what it is that current uh participants
benefit benefactors want but also
with with a one eye on the future in
terms of what what future attendance of
that service may want
and that will coincide with inevitably
work
uh with the county council and
stakeholders uh council field mentioned
health and and others and naturally yes
um
we need to develop a sheltered housing
service not that not only works for us
and and
our tenants but the needs of our
our partners
can i just ask you just to confirm
that the subsidy or the shortfall from
the sheltered
cost of the sheltered housing service
that subsidy is born by
people in our um
council owned properties the good growth
rate
is ring fence so yeah we've actually got
one vulnerable group of people
subsidizing another
different group of people that would be
correct chair so um the subsidy uh that
uh we have in mid suffolk currently will
be
um covered by uh monies into the housing
revenue account
obviously it is a ring fence paul and
tenants will pay their
their weekly rent to us as the council
when that will contribute full of
services
um we recognize and identify that those
living in sheltered are vulnerable
um or could be vulnerable um whether
that
be for a variety of reasons um but i
think we do have to consider and
part of developing the surface charge
offer going forward would be to consider
that actually
you might live within a scheme in
mid-suffolk
you might receive from the benefits of
someone visiting you or calling you
or maybe some of the the peace of mind
that safety and security gives you in
terms of living in
in one of those sites yet we might just
have uh
an individual uh possibly very elderly
living just outside the scheme doesn't
receive any of those benefits
and and who would would be contributing
to this per se so
uh yes you're correct in that statement
thank you very much could i just ask if
supporting people funds from
the county or the government via the
county pay any part in that
uh arithmetic chair if i could just come
back on that that point um uh members
may
may or may not be aware that um
traditionally
um some years ago uh sherwood housing
benefit from a supporting people
charge uh and and that benefited those
living in shared housing
that supporting people charge has has
has gone over time it's been eroded
and and has eventually gone so uh we
actually received no supporting people
funding
as as was uh from uh the county council
in in this regard uh to to provide uh
sheltered housing services
thank you for major sadden
possibly being over pedantic in this but
insofar as we have a
surplus on the hra like for this budget
year
and we have reserves brought forward to
some extent it isn't quite
just a bleak um a
a or b uh subsidizing one or the other
because there is this sort of third con
part in this which is the sort of
brought forward reserves and surpluses
if that makes sense
lovely thinking
so we got to no more questions so
does anybody wish to go to debate on
this item
no so i'm now going to ask the dominance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress in your app
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed item 11
is mca 20 31
and is the council tax hardship fund
and again i'm going to invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report
thank you i'm glad i got a drink by my
side
it's soft drink by the way i'd like to
introduce now report
mca 2031 starts on page 97 our report
back
during the early stages of the coven 19
pandemic
the government allocated to each
district council a summer money
to form a hardship fund this is
available until the 31st of march 21
was aimed at giving a council tax
discount of up to 150 pounds
to any working age household in receipt
of local council tax support
here in mid suffolk we have a strong
ethos of looking after our most
vulnerable residents
we have a generous local castle tax
reduction scheme
which allows up to 90 95 discount
on the council tax payable this actually
means that
many residents on this scheme have less
than 150 pound council tax to pay for
the year
now the number of claimants has risen
during the year in line with increasing
unemployment
and was anticipated to grow more sharply
with the end of the furlough scheme
however as the furlough scheme has now
been extended into 2021
the amount of the hardship fund spent
has in fact fallen short
of the funds available by approximately
30 percent
this report is therefore before us to
consider make a recommendation about how
the remaining balance
is allocated to those most in need of
support
and having considered the three options
set out in the report the recommended
course of action
is that a further award is made to those
that have already received
some money while retaining sufficient
money to accommodate those that will be
making
a new claim before the end of march the
level of additional award
will be adjusted to ensure that the fund
is fully allocated
but not over committed by the end of the
financial year
this ensures that the fund is used in
its entirety in accordance with the
original guidance from the government
i'd like to propose the recommendation
set out in 3.1
3.2 on page 100 and with us for a second
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead who would
like to second
uh councillor flatman chair i'm very
happy to second the report
um on the council tax hardship fund
and spending it all lovely thank you
councillor flatman
does anybody have any questions
counselor field
just a couple of points um i i note
um you you're mentioning the amount of
arrears in this fund
and i wonder if you could clarify a
couple of points there
um we're talking about um
274 people who have arrears averaging
800 and
something 485 pounds per person
that looks like about three years at the
rate we're talking about
but the largest open case i was 2795
i just wondered how anyone gets to that
level you know what
what it implies um should i be concerned
about the way we're managing
those um o-rings if you like so
that's one issue um
the second one really is there's two
statements in three one and three two
one
says you'll exhaust the funds so you're
just um
payments to get the fund exhausted uh by
the end of its
uh allotted time and then three two says
that any residual balance
will be applied i couldn't see how
there'd be a residual balance if you've
exhausted the fund thank you
thank you councilwoman thank you um
we've actually got
amy mays from the shared revenues
partnership with us today
and her team has done a fantastic job
over the this last year with
everything that's been going on with the
benefits etc with kobe so
first of all i'd like to take forward
the thanks to our cabinet
for all that work but if i could ask amy
to
if she's able to address those
particular questions that uh council
field has
erased
happy to um hopefully you can see me i
wasn't sure whether my camera was
working
um certainly councillor field you raised
the question about the arrears in the
first instance
um i would should be clear that this
amount of hardship fund won't address
arrears per se
it is to look at a residual balance so
customers who had a liability to pay in
2021
can have hardship applied to that
liability
rather than we're using the money to
clear previous year arrears
so it would only be if people had a
residual balance
for 2021 and councillor is writing that
some of our customers have got
more than one year outstanding and we
are working as best we can
to work with them to look at reducing
the areas
however particularly this year the
council took a very
soft approach on how we were going to
tackle arrears
so we've been trying to work with
customers come to an arrangement
but not pursue um arrears in a rigorous
manner at all
um as to the council a second point
about the residual
balance we are looking at making an
award a set amount
and it's likely that there will be
pennies and pence difference
so rather than um because we've got over
2 400 live customers in receipt of
working tax it's very difficult to get
it to the exact amount so if we've got
less than a few thousand we won't be
able to spread it evenly throughout
all the customers but we're looking
still to be able to exhaust that
one particular instance might be that
somebody who has only recently
claimed um council tax reduction we're
not able to back date
council tax reduction now because the
rules don't allow us to do
that so whilst they will be um
entitled to hardship it will only be
hardship
from now rather than the rest of the
year so we could use the discretionary
financial assistance
to give them an award pro rata for the
whole of the year as if they had claimed
earlier and that is our intention to use
their residual funds in that way
thank you that sounds good okay thanks
thank you councillor field thank you amy
any other questions
no
does anybody wish to debate this item
no then i'm going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the
electronic vote thank you
thank you chair members the vote is now
in progress
[Music]
just waiting on one more vote chair
thank you members uh that is nine votes
four chair that's a unanimous
thank you very much item 12
is mca 20 32
and this is the lax field neighborhood
plan
and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for planning to introduce
this report council
thank you chairman um so chairs
councillors the report before you
updates cabinet on the lex lexfield
neighborhood plan and it sets out two
recommendations which you can see on the
first page of the report
are page 105 of your papers
these are that the first that the parish
council be instructed to modify their
plan
in accordance with the independent
examiner's recommendations
and secondly uh subject to satisfactory
completion of that tasks
task it seeks approval for this plan to
be
advanced to a local referendum
um the lax field neighborhood plan
follows a
tried and tested formula
once modified it will contain 18
policies covering housing the natural
environment
design infrastructure and services
it also provides for a level of new
housing
growth that is consistent with the
requirement set out in our joint
local plan there is also a comprehensive
suite of
community actions that are linked to
individual
policies paragraph 4.2
of the report sets out the key stages
prior to
examination the examination itself
is discussed in paragraphs 4.3
to 4.5
the modifications of note update this
plan to reflect changes on the ground
in terms of both existing and
recently approved planning permissions
they also refer to last october's court
of appeal ruling
on the appropriate wording for local
green space policies
and they allow for updating supporting
text
where it refers to the current status
of the joint local plan
at paragraph 4.8 you will see
confirmation
that our officers have looked at those
modifications
and are in agreement that all should be
made
so it only remains for me to ask your
neighborhood planning officer
to continue working with the parish
council to ensure
that these modifications are made in a
timely manner
and subject to the satisfactory
completion of them
ask a cabinet to agree that this plan be
advanced to a local referendum
at the earliest opportunity so
i so move the recommendations
and ask if anyone will be willing to
second that proposal thank you thank you
councillor claremont uh yes thank you
chair
i'm absolutely delighted to second the
report on the lax field
um neighborhood plan and i'd just like
to thank
paul bryant and all the officers that
have worked on their neighborhood plan
and given us so much advice and i think
we probably started about four years ago
when we first had those meetings
um and here we are now so well done
everybody thank you
thank you councillor flatman does
anybody have any questions
does anybody wish to debate this item
so i will now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair members
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for that game is unanimous
okay thank you very much um well done
maxfield
so now going on to item 13 which is mca
20 33 and this is the will be
neighborhood
plan and i'm going to invite the cabinet
member for
planning council burn to introduce this
report
thank you chairman
this report updates cabinet on the will
be neighborhood plan
uh it sets out two recommendations
first of which i will come back to
shortly
and those recommendations uh you will be
now be familiar with the first that the
parish council be instructed to modify
their plan in accordance with the
independent examiner's recommendations
and secondly
uh that's subject to satisfactory
completion of that task
it seeks approval for this plan to be
advanced
to a local referendum
the will be neighborhood plan sets out
10 policies
grouped around three key objectives the
natural environment
housing and the built environment and
community
as set out in paragraph 4.5 of the
report the policies only required
limited change most of this work has
been
focused on ensuring that supporting tech
is up to date
especially where this refers to our
emerging joint local plan
the modification process has therefore
been been quite straightforward
and consequently has been completed
in other words the requirement for the
first recommendation
has been met
turning back quickly to the plan itself
it should provide sufficient guidance
to enable effective decision making at
the local level
so it only remains for me to ask cabinet
to agree that this plan now be advanced
to
a local referendum at the earliest
opportunity
that is the motion and
i would ask one of my colleagues to
second that please thank you tesla
thank you chair um just the same as
before i'm so delighted to bring this um
at a second this
um neighborhood plan and for such a
small community i think
they've done really really well and
again thank you to everybody who was
involved at the very beginning and
that's obviously paul
thank you so much
thank you does anybody have any
questions
anybody wish to debate this item
in which case i will ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress members
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for
lovely thank you very much and
congratulations to will be parish
for the completion of this thus far
thank you now item
the next item is a confidential minute
from the meeting on the 4th of january
and now i don't feel that it's necessary
to enter into closed
session for this unless anybody's got
any questions on the minute
so i wonder if anybody's would like to
raise their hand if they've got a
question
and then we can decide whether or not we
need to go into
a confidential session in order to prove
it
no okay so we'll remain in open open
session then
so do i have a proposal for the
uh confidential minute which is item 15
mca 20 33 now that can't be right
i think the reference is wrong on this
one because it's
the same reference as the will be
neighborhood plan but in the paper
itself it's got a
baby reference so i'll just refer to it
by its title which is the confidential
minute of mid-suffolk cabinet on monday
the 4th of january
do you have a proposal uh councillor
richardson
thank you chair um regardless of the
correct agenda number i'm happy to
propose the confidential minutes
thank you thank you councillor
richardson councillor brewster
happy to second the murderer thank you
very much
council brewster um so i'll ask the
government's officer to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair apologies about the uh
reference number that was my fault
okay let me just stop this vote now
just
okay sorry members the vote is now in
[Applause]
progress
thank you members chair that again is
unanimous nine votes for
thank you very much indeed so the
minutes of this meeting have been
confirmed and we signed
the next practical opportunity
um the next meeting is scheduled for
monday the 8th of march at 2
30 in the afternoon i declare this
meeting closed
thank you very much for your
participation everybody
you